we got the beat was released  40 years ago  give me a memory from 40 years ago if  you don't mind  mine is when we recorded it  and we went in the recording studio and  ready and raron to  get we got the beat and we played it  then we played it again then we played  it again then we played it again and  after the tenth try  our producer richard said okay let's  take a break  and he ordered pizza  there you know  okay so it was either the magic sauce  and the pizza or the stars aligned while  we were eating  but or maybe both but the 11th take was  magic and we are just so happy that  that we get to share that with you today  love being behind the scenes that's so  exciting